[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to our installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing some news involving maz
mickelson
our new grindelwald and the untitled
third fantastic beast's installment
late last year fans were hit with the
shocking news that johnny depp
who plays the role of galette
grindelwald in the fantastic beasts
franchise
was being dropped by warner bros the
departure of deb
who has been playing the dark wizard
antagonist for the first two films
left a huge hole in the franchise and
for a period
left warner brothers frantically
searching for his replacement
there were many names thrown into the
mix for his replacement
however one name came up more than any
other across the internet
maz mikkelsen it didn't take long for
maz to officially declare
that he was cast as the dark wizard
despite his willingness to accept the
role and take the torch from johnny
mickelson has been nothing but
respectful
toward the former fantastic beasts star
and publicly commented on the mata a few
months ago
well it's going to be me so that's the
difference mikkelsen quipped
then he got serious no this is the
tricky part
we're still working it out there has to
be a bridge between what johnny did
and what i'm going to do and at the same
time i also have to make it my own
but we also have to find a few links to
the previous version of the character
and some bridges so it doesn't
completely detach from what he's already
masterfully achieved
more recently mickelson released another
statement discussing how he has chosen
to approach the role
and where he feels he may have to
deviate from deb's portrayal
this is obviously a more direct
comparison because it's the next film
so we have done a few bridges that will
allow us to recognize it
but we've also said we have to make it
our own i have been a fan of johnny depp
since i saw him as a young man
and to try to bring his intensity and
his way of doing it into my work
is a no-go i have to find my own because
his is unique
and i just have to let that be and find
a different path
one thing is for sure mickelson's
grindelwald is going to be different
but i'm interested to see just how
different he takes it
both men have a sort of brooding
intensity to their acting style
but it sounds like mikkelsen may take it
somewhere else
he's a totally different actor with a
totally different skill set
but i will say this mickelson has done a
good job of taking over roles in the
past
more recently mickelson took on the role
of hannibal lecter
in nbc's hannibal the first person to
take on the role
since anthony hopkins i'm also extremely
happy to hear that nicholson is taking
it somewhere different as simply trying
to directly replicate the drop of depth
may have felt forced and that's it for
today's video
how do you think maz will do in the role
let me know in the comment section
below until next time your wizard howry
you